Oh, my god.
Ooh, you better save some
of those "Oh my gods" for later.
During coitus, of course.
Brett, what are you doing here?
I would like to throw my penis
into the ring.
And by ring, I mean your
innocence.
What?
I would be honored...
to make love to you tonight,
Billie.
Gene.
It's time to do the do.
I would never, ever have sex
with you, okay, Brett?
I would rather die a virgin!
I would rather die a virgin.
( PHONE VIBRATING )
Oh.
Billie!
Gene, did you call Brett?
Yeah, I know, not my first
option, but he's very prepared.
He already has a condom on.
And there's fliers?!
Yes, okay, but I kept
it very discrete!
I just put your first name--
Hang on, my phone's buzzing!
I have 500 "winks" from an
elderly dating app...
called “Penulti-Mates”?!
I went ahead and signed you
up for that.
Because of their oldness, the
elderly tend to be sort of...
slow moving and tender lovers!
Sort of like doing it
with a snail.
Only it's hot.
Gene, do me a favor...
don't do me any favors! Okay?
So do the favor or don't
do the favor.
Don't do the favor!
Gene, please stop helping me!
Billie, wait, wait, wait,
before you go--
How do you wear a... dress?
Hey... you know where these
snacks taste really good?
In my bed? Is that what you're
gonna say, Brett?
No, in the kitchen. There'd be
crumbs all over the bed.
I'm not a crumb monster!
Can I just have some
alone time, please? Okay?
Fair enough.
Thank you.
But if you need a shoulder to
snack on, in a dirty way--
Oh, my god! Look, I may be a
pathetic virgin...
but at least I'm not begging
for it! Okay?